hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making a big the show where i make giant
food for my friends and co-workers
today what i thought would be fun would
be to make a giant
bento box with lots of fun things inside
first
i'm gonna talk to my good friend riya
mcclenny to explain
what is a bento box why is a bento box
and how is a bento box let's talk to
riya
hi rea hey alvin what is a bento box and
what is the context behind
bento bento is essentially
a meal in a box you can bring it to
school you can bring it to office for
lunch it's rice and a couple of small
things that
can last a while they won't spoil they
won't go bad exactly
bento is meant to be eaten cold
so you want to season very well and
what kinds of foods are usually inside a
bento
rice it's a must my favorite
is tamagoyaki and fried chicken so
it's a first season you made me a giant
tamagoyaki
it's a japanese omelette it was
my mom's favorite as well when my mom
was little
she requested kamalaki all the time her
school teacher
saw that and she warned her
if you only eat tamagoyaki every day
you will turn into chicken and that made
her very scared
that's kind of messed up that's like
when when
my mom told me if you eat a watermelon
seed it'll grow into a watermelon so you
make sure you take out all the seeds
that's not true at all
what the heck one thing that i've seen
in a couple of bento pictures is hot
dogs that are cut
in a way where they almost look like
little octopuses people who make bento
try to make it look very cute or like
try to make it look like a character
so i think i have all the information
that i need
thank you for teaching us about the
world of bento i'm excited
for you i'm scared
i have my work cut out for me so i've
invited my friend inca
also a fellow buzzfeed producer we both
make videos for about to eat
go check out the channel there's a lot
of fun stuff that we're making and going
to make so welcome back inka thanks for
having me elvis yeah
inca i've heard that you've also made
bento boxes and videos about battle
boxes before can you tell me about that
i have so okay the last time i made one
on
a video was like three years ago the
ridiculously cute
bento box you will be the expert i will
be
moral support nah you'll do it with me
we'll do it together
so to start i'm going to be making the
rolled egg omelette that rie mentioned
and inka is going to be making i'm going
to make an
army of octoweenies octo sausages
little octopi wow they look like fingers
half it like this it's not obvious right
now it's going to be obvious once it
hits the water we're gonna we're gonna
cook them alive
i mean boil them while inka
is slowly assembling her army of
octoweenies
i'm going to be destroying an army of
eggs for the tamagoyaki
it's your army of eggs versus my army of
sausages why did this turn into a
competition
this is a collaborative team effort look
at this
fanning out the legs oh yeah don't say
that
okay oh that sounds weird it's that does
that sound weird well
okay well
inca i have one egg left and do you
remember what we did
in the ramen episode peggy
i feel like we should have um eggy
reborn reincarnated
you know inca seems to be a little slow
today so while
i'm gonna get so much flack for that
later tamagoyaki is usually seasoned
with a couple of things
wow i just burped oh sorry you had to
hear that so soy sauce
some instant dashi powder a good amount
of
sugar which might sound weird but is
actually delicious salt a little bit of
water
now because i am too lazy to whisk eggs
we use an immersion blender
and viciously turn them into one big egg
damn he's pissed
alvin why don't i have an immersion
blender shortcut you should have hand
whisked it
well you know uh let's just say i chose
to do the eggs for a reason
oh i knew it it looks like they're ready
for war
i have two still pet masks with nonstick
spray borrowing another technique from
the 100 egg omelet video
i'm gonna bake these in sheets and you
go
look at that and i'm gonna slowly
transfer these into the oven
while inka toils away on her weenie army
another bento box item that i'm really
excited about is the fried chicken
which is karage so instead of having
little small chunks of fried chicken
we're at making a bake so we're going to
use the whole chicken thigh
for the marinade i have soy sauce
some garlic ginger oh it smells so good
sake one egg sugar just gonna
mix this all up whoa all right this is a
little hot
but look at that oh it's coming together
good do you like karage what what are
you what are you doing back there
grabbing some um some of my special
tools
marinade is looking pretty good and i
think what makes the signature coating
is potato starch
i love frying with potato starch it just
has this really nice crisp
like rugged texture
i have really hot oil here i have the
chicken
it's only one thing left to do
all right oh it's getting hot
oh look at this color it's getting so
beautiful
dude look at this fried chicken oh boy
that does look good all right first
batch is ready to come out
i think look at that i'm actually gonna
double fry these because
these thighs are big and as they rest
they're also really juicy so some of the
juices start to come out
i think double frying helps get rid of
that water and makes it extra crispy
alrighty they've been in here for a
while look at this one
look at it a beauty
well i'm gonna keep cooking these but
are you cooking these butts
no i keep cooking these
bye aggie eggy i keep it boring
i'm gonna put on the fancy eyes remember
the ones from my video
yes those look really good oh you know
i'm on a big show making some really
tiny stuff right now
you see can you see it can you see the
ice
ready angry octo weenie
[Music]
our two different kinds today wow
the premium on the right hey don't hate
this is how i feel on youtube this is me
after makeup
vegetables are very important for bento
boxes so i think
you're going to handle the more delicate
work because you are more artistic
or maybe you just don't want to do the
work that's actually the reason why i
really don't want to handle vegetables
so i'm going to
roll my egg omelette now um you go ahead
and you do you
i'm not going to cook the tomatoes but
i'm just going to blanch the carrots
and i'll slice them up so then it'll
also make it easier for me to cut them
is everything okay over there you know
they're just a little raw but
those are massive carrots i know they're
cute i haven't cooked with carrots this
making a long time
just trying to loosen up the egg from
its little mat
over here this is a time
tested technique roll
this little break is fine you keep it
nice and tight
now this is going to go over here
no snack oh good
hungry
[Music]
it's very sweet i like it sweet and
savory
i'm gonna stamp these out i'm gonna go
with this big cookie cutter
oh it looks like a heart nice
uh okay here we go keep the wrap nice
and tight that's the most important
thing oh look at that
let's roll it up roll it up it's a big
egg baby
big boy yeah eggy eggy excellent
broccoli is good looking greener than
ever
i have eggie here beautiful baby smooth
skin
we love it i'm going to give him a face
i have a bear stamp out here i'm going
to use it to
give me a smile so that
sounded nice okay oh i love that
wait cheeks oh yay
oh it looks so cute on camera oh my god
okay so one of the most important things
about bentos is
rice yes
we are going to make rice bears
this is three entire bags i don't know
what that means but
your bags it's a lot of rice so one big
head
and then two ears that sounds like a
plan
gosh it's like building a snowball
oh yeah don't throw it at me this is not
sticking together as much as i was
hoping it would
oh smart no i don't i don't know what
i'm doing don't say don't call me smart
i don't know what i'm doing
squish it squish it compress
ugh i hope this works
yeah they didn't come out the way i
wanted it to uh you know it's okay
what are you doing is that how you feel
help you know honestly oh yeah not bad
no what the heck this is that's not a
bear that is mickey mouse
excuse me that is a bear i just want to
make sure you're happy with what you're
putting out that's all
[Music]
i just destroyed it no why is the camera
getting a close-up of this
oh my arms are burning it looks a little
bit like a joker bear right now
joker bear too big of a smile
i'm going to make a small face on a big
bear i don't know how this is going to
look but
let's get the ears
i love it oh my god wait i love this
i can't i can't all right well we have
created two monstrosities
our wonderful art team in la made a
giant bento box so now
it's time to assemble how are we going
to do this alvin we can take turns
because this is a very big box would you
like to put in the weenies and the
chicken sure
all right all you oh right now well
thanks for having me here again
welcome to my show make you think
[Music]
oh careful you worked hard on okay well
i'll just put these weenies in
now like this as you can see some of
these little octoweenies have like
very cute mouths
a little o shaped mouth and a little
leaf hat looks like a pokemon almost
thank you to the culinary team honestly
they uh added
some spice this is a lot of a lot of
babies right here
babies i thought we're in the army i
mean it's an army of babies
i'm not even i'm not even halfway there
yet
oh no he just flopped
i don't know what's happening i just
heard heavy breathing i'm trying
to pick it up okay this is gonna be a
pile of chicken
who doesn't like that right oh oh
it looks so good i'm going to do the egg
now
all right let's do big slices that's
very satisfying right
it's going to get a little messy it's
placement is a little
it's a little finicky i think that's why
they don't make tamagoyaki this big
yeah i think that's the best i'm going
to be able to get it i think it tastes
good it's just uh
very tender hey they don't look bad
thanks alvin's worried for no reason
all right i have been given this
spatula look here's the deal this is a
big
big guy and um gosh alvin i really hope
i can do this me too
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
i can't lift it okay all right i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna do it i'm gonna holy sh
she's a kid show holy moly crowley
moly's moly's all right hey no
i'm i think i got it yeah he's he's at
home
okay my turn i did it oh boy let me tell
you it's not easy
i'm gonna put the ears on later oh
oh he's sturdy he's a thick sturdy bear
the arm shaking i'm shaking how are
you going to fit all right yeah there
you go there you go
let's get one of your ears on little
buddy oh that's a little high that's
fine
there you go all right some tomatoes at
the bottom
oh yeah oh yeah
wow we did it well i'm so glad you came
today
i don't think i could have envisioned a
better box i know i'm pretty proud of us
it is probably 50 pounds
we done did good yay
anko would you like a plate yes please
that's a huge plate
this is the only plate we have oh this
is the making of the course
oh no no
cheers
[Music]
oh my god so tender yeah and that potato
starts coating oh my gosh
we did it alvin we did it great job this
looks so good julie
i'm so happy this looks way better than
what i had imagined
and i knew it was going to look good
because you were here so i'm glad we are
very hungry
and we like what we made exactly we just
made like 50 bento boxes
no big deal 100 yeah so um if you'll
excuse us
we're gonna take some time alone bye
[Music]
you